let's see what else there let's see what
else let's see what else the Internet is
gasping this casket you know it's great
being able to read your really do it
again oh I got it let's see what else
the end another last try and it's yours
hi I'm Joey King and I'm Joel Courtney
and today we will be doing the wired
here we go so the header here is how
Joey King
how did Joey King and become famous
became famous hahaha that's hysterical
wait Joey King's famous Joey King did
not know that she was famous but if she
were to answer that question to the best
of her ability it would be lots of hard
work a good answer okay
how did Joey king and Sabrina carpenter
meet I'm actually curious about this too
because you guys have been friends
forever
we've been friends yeah Sabrina
carpenter and Joey King met many many
years ago at like a charity event
Sabrina came over to me and was like hi
I'm Sabrina what's funny is like we
weren't always super close like for the
first several you guys were our
friendship we would like hang out once
every like year and it was like the
funnest thing in the world we don't know
why it took us so long to become as
close as we are now how old is joey king
kissing booth how will this do weekend
kissing booth I'm in the first kissing
booth I am seventeen but in real life I
am about to be 21 okay last one how does
Joey King stay in shape people actually
asked that question to Google that's so
funny to me I'd go through phases of
like working out a ton and then not
working out at all and then I go through
phases of eating a ton and then eating
clean like like it's kind of weird I
don't have like a system especially when
we're shooting the kissing booth because
it took so long to film it I started out
like working out so hard everyday so
healthy and then just like
went out the window and I was like I
guess I'll just eat fried food and
peanut butter shakes every day like
because who really cares pick shapes
okay are you ready Jill Courtney when
was Jill Courtney born I was born
January 31st 1996 good year good vintage
of person timing I'm not really great
with the zodiac signs but I've been told
that I'm on the cusp between Aquarius
and another one because the 31st is like
so close it can like go either way so
apparently I have a split personality
do you know what my sign is to give you
a hint
rawr I'm a Mars
I'm a Leo it's fine leo gotcha I think
roar is like pretty the lion like yeah
that's true whatever whatever okay what
has Jill Courtney been in what a diva's
dump no okay so I started my career in
super 8 2010 that was actually my first
audition I'd never done anything before
that I did a quick stint with CW in the
messenger's a few years ago buy more
movies and then the kissing booth
happens in oh my goodness 2017 is that
right yep and then it came out in 2018
honestly like it has just been a the
best ride I've realized I've been
working for a decade now which is how
tall is Jill Courtney in feat when I
take my shoe and I just keep stacking
them up until they reach the top of my
head I reach about 12 shoes no I'm about
6 foot 6 1 depending on the shoe is your
Courtney as well you would actually you
actually maybe think so because we are
like so close that we sometimes finish
each other's
says dude you're the brother I never
wanted you no no we're not related but
man sometimes feelings we are all right
next line Oh is Joey King is Joey King a
man hey Joey
are you man I regret to inform you I am
NOT a man
my name is a man's name I pained after
my grandfather who to my knowledge was a
lovely guy he passed before I was born
but I am a woman is Joey King Australian
I am NOT Australian I am American well
you know 23 me I'm not American but I'm
American born in America but I
understand why people were confused on
that because I was with Jacob so I get
it is Joey King French Joey do you
sprechen zie penny Oh Whaley is Joey
King related to Stephen King okay I've
never actually thought about that are
you I'm not related to Stephen King I do
love Stephen King books though but no I
have no relation to Stephen King at all
is Joey King vegan I am NOT vegan I try
to be careful about my meat intake and I
don't really eat dairy if I can help it
but I am NOT I am NOT vegan
unfortunately I respect vegans more than
like ever imagined though I've always
wanted to really be a vegan
I'm trying sometimes but it's hard it's
very hard and this is morbid but I've
always had like a death-row meal like
that sounds terrible like whatever but I
always said I was gonna be my grandma's
brisket and a peanut butter milk shake
so the opposite of vegan sorry but I
also love vegan food so much here we go
Joel Courtney is the header is Jill
Courtney related to Jai Courtney I'm not
related to Jai Courtney seems like a
really awesome dude though I'd love to
do
we've heard it here first folks not
related
Joel Courtney Moscow Idaho yeah so my
family moved to Moscow Idaho when I was
like four years old so that's my
hometown that's where I grew up that's
where it's raised chai was about 14
years old started filming and then I've
just been all over the place really it's
still home it's still home for sure so
Courtney oh my god for some reason my
brain read that as Joel Courtney SPF a
jewel Courtney super a nothing to do
with sunscreen no but I did start my own
sunscreen line and it only is SPF 8 oh
my god you're so dumb I love you so much
I was like on these Google Joel Courtney
SPF 30 uh super 8 is my first movie that
was my first audition I mean that was
really just like a baptism of fire I
remember showing up to set and I think I
scared the entire crew because I was
saying like what does that thing do like
what's the purpose of that and they're
like well that's the camera and I'm like
cool cool cool so what's that dude and
they're like oh what are we in for
that's so cute though is Joel Courtney
related to Ross Lynch I am not related
to rest Lynch but I'm friends with him
there's this little league and we play
softball sometimes I became friends with
his brother and sister they invited me
to play one time and then that's
basically all we do like I don't even
really know them outside of softball you
know those old softball friends we all
have them Joey King that's the header
who is actress Joey King she does Joey
King have a twin no I do how do I do
that oh sorry my bad hey Joey do you
twin no I don't have to UM I have a
sister though that look we look a lot
alike
her name's hunter King she's my best
friend al Oliver so much um and we get
mistaken for twins a lot I get tweeted a
lot of photos of people that look like
me which is so weird people are like I
think I'm your doppelganger
is Joey King nice I can answer this one
[Music]
nice dude love a good reputation ruin
let's go I'd like to think I'm pretty
friendly I mean listen I'm not gonna go
around humble bragging that I'm a nice
lady but I'm not gonna say I'm a mean
lady because I definitely know that I'm
not I'll take this one for joy because
it is hard to like speak on this one for
yourself Joey is the nicest she's
awesome and she's literally like one of
my favorite people that I've ever worked
with or not so moving on before I start
crying
I'm Joey King singing yes Joey King can
sing in the comfort of her I just
actually posted a cover like yesterday
of Vienna Bible it was really good thank
you buddy I love to sing it's so much
fun I've always wanted to do a musical
one day that'd be amazing
up again it's fun all right she'll
Courtney - Courtney best friend so buddy
what do you have to say for yourself so
my best friend is my fiance Mia shoaling
all right sir hahahaha gotcha me is my
best friend - that's fine no she is you
she is the best Joey King tight second
oh you don't have to lie to me it's fine
I know I'm on the list somewhere at
least what does Jill Courtney look like
now you're longer than he looks like a
gosh darn stud next question Jill
Courtney quotes you know it's actually
funny about this
I kept a quote list of myself but it was
negative quotes so you know in traffic
people slow down for a car accident and
they're called rubberneckers
I was one time driving in LA and my
dad's riding shotgun and I go oh those
stupid redneck errs they're slowing us
all down I said redneck errs instead of
rubberneckers
so like the quote list that I kept was
of like the dumb things that I said yeah
yeah yeah no I I don't think I've ever
really said anything that was like worth
quoting is Joel Courtney married I am so
excited to get married I love my fiance
Nia shoutout to you if you're watching
this yeah shoutout to you your
watching this I love YouTube yeah almost
so close right around the corner alright
what Joey king is our headline what is
Joey King hype no I'm just I'm a shorty
you know I'm not very tall I wasn't
blessed with like tall jeans it's only
five three that's a good height though
that's not bad I mean it's a good height
it's whatever just like thanks grandma
whatever your for Friday like whatever
okay what is joking favorite color blue
paper color but like what kind of blue
blue is vain what kind of honestly all
blue any kind of shade of blue I like
lighter blues I guess but I'm never
gonna turn away a tree to blue okay what
is Joey King doing now what are you
doing right now I'm doing this crazy
zoom interview I'm drinking this tea
it's quite good and I took off my shoes
and I'm writing cute little socks with
hearts on them so I'm like I'm doing
really well right now living your best
life
what is Joey King number Joey what's
your phone number do you the passengers
you should put it on blast five five
five five five five right I'm not gonna
give my number out oh man the header is
Jill Courtney kill Courtney as a kid I
think my third grade teacher would have
described me as a goofy slacker a little
bit of a space cadet really and I still
AM as you you know wonder how my third
grade teachers doing her name was mrs.
Voorhees who's a lovely lady my name is
mrs. Jordan nice does Joel Courtney have
a brother I actually have two brothers
I'm the youngest of four chantels the
oldest and then Caleb and Josh are my
two older brothers they're both married
they've got kids the kids adore me they
call me uncle Joel which is just the
cutest thing in the world yeah as
opposed to a name that you know wasn't
yours yeah you know like hey that guy
hey uncle Ken that might be a little
weird Jill okay
photo shoot girl do you like doing photo
shoots too so I'm actually very
uncomfortable doing photo shoots I don't
really know my like
azar like how to like yeah thank you
guys so much for watching thank you to
all the people who googled the
interesting stuff about me that was fun
thank you for being interested in us how
awesome we are to have just super cool
fans super cool fans super funny where
questions am i mmm I don't know TBD TBD